i want to go back now to this viral
story of a 10 year old in ohio
impregnated after being raped
and subsequently going to indiana for an
abortion because of ohio's strict
abortion laws now we covered the story
as it was reported a week or two ago was
either early last week or late the
previous week
and it's an incredibly disturbing story
not surprisingly many on the right said
it was just a made-up story and we're
going to get to that in the second part
of this segment but that's not where i
want to start where i want to start is
the follow-up to the story which is that
an arrest has now been made of the
alleged perpetrator and this is part of
what has now shifted the narrative from
the american right on the story
which we will get to in due time so
here's the latest the columbus dispatch
reporting arrest made in rape of ohio
girl that led to indiana abortion
drawing international attention now part
of the reason why it drew international
attention national and international was
that this happened in the immediate
aftermath of the supreme court uh
announcing that roe v wade is no more
that the fundamental right to an
abortion in most cases in the country is
no more and people like south dakota
governor christie gnome
the mississippi house speaker whose name
i forget and others were asked what
about cases where a kid is raped and
impregnated 12 year old was the example
that was often given
would you feel comfortable forcing them
to carry a child to term and one of the
reactions was these are imaginary
situations these are mere hypotheticals
we don't deal in hypothetical and very
quickly we had a real story and that was
much of why the story became viral in
the way that it did well the follow-up
is the is uh the following
a columbus man has been charged
with impregnating a ten-year-old ohio
girl who's traveled to indiana to seek
an abortion led to international
attention following the supreme court
overturning roe v wade and the
activation of ohio's abortion law
gerson fuentes 27 years old was arrested
tuesday after police say he confessed to
raping the child on at least two
occasions he's since been charged with
rape
a felony in the first degree in ohio
columbus police were made aware of the
girl's pregnancy through a referral by
frankly franklin county children's
services made by her mother on june 22nd
on june 30 the girl underwent a medical
abortion in indianapolis so first and
foremost
the indiana abortion part was a real
part of the story the right was
desperate to say that's fake that's fake
and let's find whatever doctors are
committing crimes here it was a real
part of the story
hewn the detective
also testified that dna from the clinic
in indianapolis is being tested against
samples from fuentes as well as the
child siblings to confirm contribution
to the aborted fetus as you can imagine
if that is confirmed this will be an
open and shut case now one other
interesting element here that i will
discuss
franklin county municipal court judge
cynthia ebner said the case did not
warrant fuentes who is believed to be an
undocumented immigrant to be held
without bond
ebner said a high bond was necessary due
to fuentes being a possible flight risk
and for the safety of the child
um
the bond was set at two million dollars
and it is unclear whether the individual
would be able to make that bond so a few
different things here number one
undocumented whoop that's a perk up word
for fox news fox news suddenly cares
about the story again when it was the
rape of a ten-year-old with a pregnancy
but unable to get an abortion that the
the story might be fake and it was not
an interesting story all of a sudden now
that the perpetrator the believed
perpetrator who has allegedly confessed
and whose guilt may be proven by dna
very soon is undocumented now they care
about the story but they're spinning it
and we'll talk about that in the next
segment now of course if there's a dna
match this is going to be an open and
shut case and we will soon know that
many of you emailing me saying if there
isn't a case that requires uh no bond
wouldn't it be this one because isn't
the individual if indeed he is an
undocumented immigrant potentially a
flight risk to get out of the country i
think that that's absolutely true and
it's weird to me that that bond was
granted that being said we don't know
the financial situation of this
individual two million dollar bond may
be an impossibility
uh and even if you have to come up with
ten percent with a bail bondsman two
hundred thousand may be an impossibility
we just don't know it may effectively be
no bond don't know the answer to that
one other aspect to this
very often in child rape cases i get
emails from people in the audience
saying
i can't wait for this guy to end up in
prison
where you know they'll often say
something like where bubba
is going to give this guy an even
stricter punishment than the time in
prison talking of course about prison
rape i've said this before and i will
say it again
no matter how vile the crime
and no matter how strict the sentence
which this is a very serious alleged
crime and the sentence should be very
severe
the the counting on
the lack of security in our prisons
so that people also are raped as part of
an additional punishment i think is
absolutely disgusting when and and i'm
not denying that it happens
but when people say you know child
molesters have it tough in prison
they're gonna end up rape themselves and
i like that
we have a problem in american prisons
that they are unable to keep inmates
safe
it should if you believe there should be
stricter punishments for certain crimes
well we can lobby for them we can we can
vote we can find elected officials or
whatever that will change the law to
make the punishment stricter but
relishing
off the record punishments that are the
result of
faulty prisons that aren't able to
protect inmates like for example prison
rape of child molesters it's very hard
for me to say that that that's a good
thing or pre the punishment should be
that doled out by the justice system and
if this person is indeed the perpetrator
it should be a very severe punishment
but the the relishing the prison rape
stuff hard for me to get behind that
okay so that's the update on the story
let's now go to the right wing reaction